كان الفخر كبيرا والامل كبير بالنسبه
لكثيرين بعد مسار المشرف واداء مشرف يخرج
اسود الاطلس من انتصار الى انتصار مباراه
تاريخيه ساخنه مشحونه امام جمهور احمر
بنسبه 80% في الملعب والانجاز ايضا
تاريخيا نصف نهائي في قطر لاعبوا المغرب
نافسو انفسهم اولا نافسو حواجز الخوف امام
افواجا من عمالقه الكره عبر البطوله
وكسروا ارقام الخصوم وارقامهم الشخصيه
المغرب يخسر امام حامل اللقب فرنسا لكنها
ليست نهايه الرحله انما هي بدايه جديده
للكره العربيه
رفعتم سقف احلامنا كثيرا وغدا لن يكون
كامس كلمه منا في صباح العربيه الكتب
واحاديث الناس ستذكر مراتكم غير المسبوقه
و ستحفظها للابد في سجلات قصص المونديال
المذهله انتم ابطال واستحقيتم كل ثانيه من
ذلك الانجاز فاستمتعوا وعود الينا في
الميداليه الفرنسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على كل حال سنخصص الجزء الاكبر من ساعات
الصباحيه الاولى في صباح العربيه للحديث
عن مباريات كاس العالم وخصوصا مباراه يوم
امس
لعبد الجواد رشاد يسعد هالصباح عبد الجواد
اهلا بك معنا عبد الجواد قبل ان نبدا
بالحديث عن الارقام ولغه الارقام في
المونديال قراءه سريعه لما حصل امس
المنتخب المغربي
المنتخبات العربيه في المستقبل بصمه الذي
يمحيها احد اداء مشرف من العيار الثقيل
يعني نلاحظ اداء كرواتيا امام الارجنتين
واداء المغرب امام فرنسا مستويات عاليه
جدا يعني الحظ له بعض الشيء وقوه
من المغرب
شو في ارقام لافته على مر التاريخ على مر
مباريات كاس العالم
اليوم بعالم الارقام بانها لم تحدث في
تاريخ كره القدم بان بطل كاس العالم في
هذه النسخه الارجنتين او فرنسا قد خسر من
منتخب عربي في دوري المجموعه الجميع يذكر
كيف سقطت الارجنتين السقوط المدوي امام
المنتخب السعودي وكيف سقطت فرنسا امام
تونس هذه هي المعلومه الامر طبعا المدرب
المنتخب الفرنسي
له فرصه كبيره هو كان قد توج كلاعب توجع
كمدرب لكن هناك زال هناك بيكنج باودر
كانوا قد احرز اللقب كاللاعبين ومدربين
لكن الشام فرصه للتربه واحراز اللقب للمره
الثانيه كمدرب طبعا منتخب فرنسا اليوم هو
اقوى هجوم في نسخه قطر لديه ثلاث عشر
اهداف ايضا منتخب فرنسا لم يخسر عندما
تقدم بالتسجيل منذ مباراه المركز الثالث
عام 82 اماما بولندا ايضا المنتخب المغربي
في عالم الارقام تلقى في المباراه في هذا
الدور هدفين وهو ضعف ما تلقاه خلال
مبارياته الخامسه لذلك بصمه المغرب هي
واضحه بشكل كبير المباراه النهائيه ستكون
بين بطلين الارجنتين وفرنسا لكن لم يتواجا
نتابع اجواء المباراه وخصوصا من المغرب من
الرباط
احتفالات مغربيه ولو محدوده بعد هزيمه
المنتخب المغربي وخروجه من المربع الذهبي
بعد خساره بهدفين لصفر في نصف نهائي كاس
العالم في قطر مع ذلك هي الجماهير
المغربيه تحتفل في تحيه لاسود الاطلس في
اول الوصول لهم الى نصف نهائي
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
كاتحرق النجاح دائما مغربيه احنا ما نحطوش
يدينا دائما الى القمه ان شاء الله
بالمنتخب ديالنا المغربي
[موسيقى]
يعني اكثر المتفائلين ما كانش كي توقعات
سيناريو همم المنتخب المغربي دابا في
وصلنا نصف النهائي ايه مشكل الاصابات وحتى
التقدير في المباراه يعني كان بعد تقديرات
ولكن كتبقى انك خرجتي امام بطل العالم
حيث المنتخب
احنا فرحانين بزاف المنتخب المغربي ديالنا
حيث شقدم واحد همم واحد الفرحه يعني انجاز
تاريخي ماشي ماشي ديما كتكون واش تبارك
الله تاهل كاس العالم وصلناه النصف
النهائي هذا بحداته
واعمل مصر ايضا متابعه لاصطاء مباراه
المغرب فرنسا في نصف النهائي نتعرف على
اراء الجمهور المصري والمغربي بعد اللقاء
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله هدف حدثته انجاز وصلنا المربع
الذهبي
وحنا حزنانين ولكن ديالك الكره فيها ربح
وفيها خساره والحمد لله هو الماتش كان
جميل جدا
والمغاربه لعبوا يعني كلم يعني عملوا
الجهد كبير بس الحظ ما كانش معهم وكفايه
ان هم وصلوا للمربع الذهبي
فريق محترم وفريق يعني كله نجوم بصراحه
شرفنا احنا كنا بنشجعوا كانه مصر
[موسيقى]
في الرياض محمد حامد يسعد صباح محمد وايضا
مره اخرى بعبد الجواد زميلنا مننا وفينا
اهلا فيك
ونذهب معاكم الان الى مراسلنا لكن هو بعد
قليل نعرف اجواء المباراه خلينا نشوف محمد
اليوم متابعه عليه احداث يوم امس قراءه
سريعه اولا
الامور العربيه احنا عشنا مع منتخب المغرب
واقع اجمل من الحلم
بمنتهى الامانه امس منتخب المغرب اصل فينا
شيء جديد قد يبكي الانسان فرحا او يبكي
حزنا او الما امس كان فيه دمعه طموح لاول
مره في منطقتنا انا لما شفت الطفل بيبكي
في البث المباشر اثناء المباراه انا
تحليلي ان دي دمعه طموح في طموح زرع في
لحظه طموح ولدت على يد منتخب المغرب هذا
الطموح لا يشمل كره القدم فقط يشمل كل شيء
كسرنا حواجز كثيره باختصار هذا الجيل كما
قلت من قبل اصبح لديكم سبت جديد وكان نقدر
نفعل اي شيء في الكره وغير الكره
في المغرب يعني هي انت قلت دموع تمثل
الطموح وانا اقول بانه يمثل هذا الطموح
مستقبل منتخباتنا العربيه كيف ينظر هذا
الطفل وكيف نحن ننظر الى المنتخبات
العربيه في المستقبل
بنوع من الحزن وانت امام منتخب فرنسا
منتخب فرنسا بالمناسبه قولا واحدا افضل
منتخب كره قدم في العالم فقط
[ضحك]
بالمناسبه انا همم ولكن
رياضي لا فكره الحياه لا لو تسمحي لي ان
الشخصي الاعلام يكون موضوعي وليس حياتي
هناك فرق كبير بين يعني استطيع ان ادافع
عن وجهه نظرك الحديث عن منتخب الارجنتين
بما يقنعك بما يقنع المشاهد ومن يقتنع
اهلا وسهلا ومن لا يقتنع فيها وجهه نظره
لها كل الاحترام عايز اقول باختصار انه
رغم عشق المنتخب الارجنتين انا شايف منتخب
فرنسا
في تاريخ كره القدم لكن في اللحظه الرهينه
ارى امكانيات مبابي افضل هذه هي الواقعيه
او الموضوعيه
يعني في نقاط عده سنناقشها وسنعود اليك
ايضا فيها فيما يتعلق بارقام في للمنتخبات
العربيه على مر التاريخ واهمها المنتخب
المغربي خصوصا بعد وصوله لنصف النهائي لكن
نذهب الى الدوحه لنعيش اجواء يوم امس فهد
الشهري يسعد هالصباح يا فهد فهد امس من
تابع مباراه المغرب كان يرى ان اللون
الاحمر هو الطاغي اللون الاحمر والاخضر
يعني كان الجمهور مغربي كل العرب جاؤوا من
كل بقاع الارض من كل الدول العربيه ليشجع
منتخب المغرب امام فرنسا يوم امس كيف كانت
الاجواء ما بعد المباراه والنتيجه
نعم كانت الاجواء نادين استثنائيه كانك
امس تحديدا في الرباط في المغرب كان اللون
الاحمر في كل مكان حضر الجميع بتذكره
وبدون تذكره الملعب كان مكتر تماما استاد
البيت
جميعا طبعا من غادر من المغرب لم يصل هنا
ولم يغادر بالطائره الا كان معه تذكره
يعني تجاه امس وصل اخر اربع طائرات وصلت
صباح الامس واتجهوا فورا الى الملعب لكن
دول مجاوره المغاربه اللي همم موجودين هنا
في الدوحه كان كثير يعمل بالحصول على
التذكره حتى شاهدنا بعض
المواطنين المغاربه او المتعاطفين يبكون
قبل قبل المباراه لعدم الحصول على التذكره
فكان يوم عاطفي الكل تعاطف الكل حتى لم
يزعل من نتيجه المباراه كامله فخور بما
قدم المنتخب المغربي همم اللي في الملعب
ضلوا بعد المباراه يحيون اللعيبه على
الانجاز نادي صباح مختلف راح نتجول معك في
اقدم قاعده يسمونها قاعده او مقهى في
الدوحه
ونسال المتابعين هنا عن شعورهم وانطباعهم
عن انجاز المنتخب المغربي هذه قهوه نعمه
السلطه
هذا اولا ههه
برد شويه لكن احنا الان في قهوه نعمه
الاجواء يعني
هذا اللي العم ابو فرج اقدم واحد في
هالقعده من 20 سنه وهو جلسه نفس الجلسه
هذا عمنا
بقول لك هارد لك هزيمه المغرب امس والله
شوف
قول لي انا قول حق العرب
المنتخب
حلوه بس قدر الله ما شاء فعل
فرنسا انت عباره انت واخذ البطوله ارفعه
راسها العرب
المنتخب المغربي
نادين الكل فخور بندخل مغربي هذا العام
ابو فرج السعيد جدا الكل رافع راسه يا
خساره ولكن ليس خساره الاهم الاهم تحققوا
المنتخب المغربي
بالوصول للاربعه الكبار في كاس العالم انت
يعني عزمتني على الفطور انا كان بودي اصلا
اكون مكانك هيك منه بريحك بالصوت وبعيش
اجواء الساعات الحاسمه من كاس العالم شو
رايك
خلاص مواقف موافق تم تم انا جاهز تذكره
المباراه جاهزه هذه
واكيد فهد احنا بنشير اذا اذا انا مش
غلطانه ذكرني انه انت ارجنتيني بنتياز
ارجنتيني بامتياز انا اللي بعرفوا
طبعا الارجنتيني
لانه كان عندي احساس انه المغرب حيغادر
ولا كنت انا مغربي قلبا وقالبا لكن الان
لا انام على الارجنتين وان شاء الله الكاس
يرفعوا ميسي باذن الله يوم الاحد ان شاء
الله طيب هذه امنياتك في اماني اخرى لفراق
اخرى ونشكرك جزيل الشكر مراسل صباح
العربيه فهد الشهري من الدوحه شكرا ان شاء
الله
يا رب
طيب اذا كانت هذه هي الاجواء في سوق الان
ولحظنا يعني الساعه الان مبكرا 8:30 صباحا
والاجواء يعني نشطه ناس يعني موصل الليل
بالنهار
شخصيه معروفه وغني عن التعريف يعني هو
يجلس في مكانه ويتابع مباريات كره القدم
يعني اذكره من كاس اسيا عام 2011
لما كان يخسر اي فريق او حتى نجوم الكبار
في المباريات السابقه كلنا نشوف الدموع
وحسره وقلم وحتى فيه قلم بالنسبه للمدرب
امس بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي لحظنا في فخر
رغم انهم خسروا لكن في تشجيع من المدرب في
حتى شموخ من اللاعبين كيف بنفصل هذه
النفسيه
خلال كاس العالم المغرب كانت قد قدمت عام
86 اداء مشرف وغادره البطوله من الدور 16
ايضا السعوديه قررت هذا الانجاز عام 94
والجميع يذكر ما قدمته الجزائر عام 2014
والمباراه البطوليه البطوليه امام المانيا
حامل طبعا لذلك نلاحظ بان المغرب اليوم
صعبه المهم على المنتخبات العربيه القادمه
هنا اسمحي لي ان نتوجه للاستاذ محمد يعني
استاذ محمد اليوم المنتخبات العربيه اصبحت
مطالبه بالوجود وتقديم الاداء الرائع يعني
لا اليوم لا توجد حجه لا لمصر ولا لتونس
ولا للمغرب ولا للجزائر ولا للسعوديه ولا
للعراق بعدم الوجود في نهائيات كاس العالم
مساله التاهل مبدئيا تكون اسهل عدد
المنتخبات هيكون اكبر فرق اكبر في النسخه
القادمه بس خلاص زي ما انت قلت احنا
طموحنا اكبر من مساله التاهل ومجرد التوجه
نقطه مهمه جدا حينما يتحقق مثل هذا
الانجاز على الساحه العالميه سالت بتزرع
الطموح في اجيال القادمه الاجيال اللي
جايه خلاص كسرت الحواجز امامها مساله انه
يذهب بعيدا في مشاركه عالميه زرعت بداخله
خلاص انتهى الامر ويجب كما قلت ان كنت
محضر القادم ليس مجرد التواجد بل تقديم
مستويات مشرفه والوصول الى ابعد نقطه
ممكنه في كل بطوله مشارك فيها
اليوم يعني كسرت مثلا صور النمطيه بالنسبه
لفكره اللاعب الاوحد واللاعبين الكبار ولا
خوف امام الكبار بعد اليوم
هو هو كره القدم عموما بعد كريستيانو
رونالدو وميسي واعتقد هم بيقتربوا من
نهايه مسيرتهم عادت مره اخرى الى فكره
الاداء الجماعه من المؤكد ومن مكاسب من
مكاسب هذا المونديال انه زرع فكره ال- ال-
كما قلت الطموح داخل ليس فقط منتخب المغرب
كثير من المنتخبات اسره الحواجز بس في
نقطه خلينا دائما انا بحب اروح للجانب
الاخر اتمنى ان يكون مساله تاثير ان
البطوله اقيمت على ارض عربيه واللاعب
المغربي يشعر بنوع من الارتياح وكانه بين
جمهور وهو بالفعل بين جمهوره ان يكون
العامل الناس نفسه كان اساسي في هذا
الانجاز اتمنى ان لا يكون ذلك احنا لدينا
البدايه صحيح صحيح يعني يعني ممكن يكون
الموضوع مش مؤكد بهذه الطريقه بس بشكل عام
احنا عندنا مشكله هي ميزه واقف في نفس
الوقت ان احنا عاطفيين شويه او شويه
اللاعب العربي يعني زي ما بيقولوا الجيران
انت او الروح بتزرع فيه مساله والاداء
القتالي ولكن لا زال بينقصنا يتفق مع
زميلي مساله
الاداء اللي فيه وعي تكتيكي يعني منتخب
فرنسا بالامس انا في رايي يعني احنا
بالعاطفه شفنا منتخب فرنسا اداءه اقل من
المغرب امس
اشكرك يعني اللي يدقق في اداء منتخب فرنسا
بالامس تكتيكيا كان افضل يعني يدرك ماذا
يريد من المباراه يحترم المنتخب المغربي
دي مساله اعداد نفسي جيد مساله
10 سنوات على راس الجهاز الفني فهناك حاله
من الاستقرار المساله لم تكن ابدا سهله
بالامس
ومنتخب فرنسا
قولا واحدا افضل منتخب في العالم في
اللحظه الراهنه منتخب فرنسا قيمه السوقيه
تتجاوز مليار يورو يعني لك ان تتخيل في
العالم
منتخب الارجنتين طرف الاخر في المباراه
النهائيه ربما يكون نصف هذه القيمه
السوقيه فقط
فرنسا تقريبا
اذا لم يتوج ميسي بكاس العالم تكون كره
القدم خانت نفسها ولم تخن ميسي لان ميسي
في رايي اعتبر ستيتمنت في نوع من المبالغه
بس انا مقتنع به كاس العالم في حاجه لميسي
كما ميسي في حاجه لكاس العالم حينما يقال
بعد اجيال وبعد سنوات انه مونديال 22 وقطر
في حاجه الاسم ميسي والمنطقه في حاجه
اسمها ميسي الى الان نتذكر وستظل كل
الاجيال تتذكر مارادونا في 86 في المكسيك
الصوره الذهنيه للمكسيك صنعت باسم مرضانه
لكن تتخيل هذه البطوله
يعني لا يغضب مني مشجعين منتخب فرنسا او
كذا وجزئيه عايز اوضحها على السريع علشان
تكون الامور واضحه مسي له اربع اعداء
عشاق رونالدو وعشاق رونالدو ليس لاعب كره
رونالدو مش عايز اقول فاشونيستا
بالاضافه
القدرات والكرويه اكمل لك العدو الثاني هو
عشاق ريال مدريد ولهم كل الاحترام
[موسيقى]
هو مارادونا عشاق مارادونا لانهم دائما
يتحدثون عن فكره انه ميسي ينقصه كاس
العالم لكي يصبح مثل مارادونا سريعا العدو
الرابع
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى خلق الناس ما بتحبش
الابداع مبتحبش المتعه بدون سبب يعني هو
حينما يرى ايقونه متالقه بهذا الحد هو لا
يريد ان يرى نجاحها في حاله مستمر
شكرا جزيلا لكما محمد حامد وشكرا عبد
الجواد شكرا